we talked about this letter that David
Garrow the biographer who's who's worked
on Barack Obama
and he's not just a biographer like he's
doing a hit piece on Obama or something
this is a guy he won the Pulitzer Prize
for biography in 1987 this is a very
serious liberal biographer and he's
writing this this biography of Obama he
says Obama's Memoir dreams from my
father is a work of fiction I know it
Obama knows it Obama knows that I know
know it when when David Guerra met with
Obama in the Oval Office Obama kind of
taunted him about the details of his
life he wouldn't show him and then this
guy found a letter
that Obama had written to uh to his
girlfriend at the time
this is back in 1982 and part of it was
redacted by the girlfriend and Guerra
said well why why is this redacted and
she said it deals with homosexuality
that's all we know well now we have the
unredacted letter
here is what Obama said
about his uh sexual orientation
in regard to homosexuality I must say
that I believe this is an attempt to
remove oneself from the present a
refusal perhaps to perpetuate the
endless farce of Earthly life
you see I make love to men daily but in
the imagination
now this I'm not just going to make fun
of Obama or try to gossip about him or
anything like that this is a profound
statement it's written Like A pompous
young young man would write but Obama
was only 21 years old at the time and he
was a pretty clever obviously ambitious
kid so not surprised that he would write
in that style
says in regard to homosexuality I must
say that I believe this is an attempt to
remove oneself from the present a
refusal perhaps to perpetuate the
endless farce of Earthly life now of
course I don't think Earthly life is a
farce
this is a very cynical atheist way of
talk it's a farce this hellish facade of
the world that we're talking about I
know I think the world is full of
meaning of course and that it doesn't
it's not a farce at all it's a happy
comedy like Dante would talk about but
he says homosexuality is a way to remove
oneself from
the process of generation that's true
that's obviously true and he says I make
love to men daily but in my imagination
so he's saying I have homosexual desires
but I don't carry them out and I I was
saying a couple of weeks ago
I think that social conservatives are a
little too harsh here
because a lot of them want to kind of
make fun of Obama for for appearing to
be a little bit light in the loafers but
what he's saying is I have homosexual
desires and I'm suppressing them
and I think well it
what's he supposed to do isn't that good
isn't that what the social conservatives
want
social conservatives who
don't have this problem that Obama has
it's very easy for us to say well haha
you know he he he's fantasizing about
men
but imagine if you were like him and you
had these homosexual desires today you
would just be told well you got to carry
that out but Obama's saying no I do want
to be even if it's a it seems like a
silly farce I do want to participate in
the process of creating life I do want a
wife I do want a family I do what he
probably obviously had political
Ambitions I do want to pursue my
political Ambitions and so I'm going to
subordinate my my sexual desires to that
isn't that shouldn't
we as social conservatives have a little
bit of Grace
for people like Obama who maybe have you
know slightly eccentric sexual desires
and say oh well he all right he's doing
basically the thing that he wants to do
now the letter gets even crazier
because Barack Obama doesn't just say
that he's got these homosexual desires
He suggests that he's a little bit
as efforts right now go to geniusell.com
that dark spot on your face is it still
bothering you what about all those sun
spots all over your body now you can
watch them disappear safely and quickly
in three quick minutes genu sells dark
spot luxury system does exactly what it
sounds like by using the world famous
microdermabrasion before the Dark Spot
Corrector you will see the dark spots
disappear before your very eyes
instantly smoothly and luxuriously
you'll be amazed at how quick you'll see
results are 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to genucell.com Knowles
right now to order the new dark spot
treatment system today say goodbye to
those pesky dark spots tomorrow that is
geniusell.com
right now save over 70 off geniusell's
most popular package that includes this
dark spot system I love geniusell I
especially love the founder who's a
Coptic Christian from Egypt who fled
Egypt for the American dream and has a
great company with a great product go to
genucel.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s here's what Obama said
about his
gender identity
my mind is androgynous to a great extent
and I hope to make it more so until I
can think in terms of people not women
as opposed to men but in returning to
the body I see that I have been made a
man and physically in life I choose to
accept that contingency
I love I love that expression I give
Obama a lot of credit I have greater
respect for Obama's intellect and and
willpower actually
after reading that than I did before and
I know all the other conservatives are
going to make fun of him and call them a
FANUC or whatever but
this is really
this was commonplace thinking 20 years
ago 30 years ago now it's pretty rare
this is my mind is androgynous into blah
blah blah okay is a 21 year old pompous
kid and he's a liberal so he's saying oh
I'm so expansive nothing no definition
can contain me man I'm just I'm like a
little I'm a woman in the morning a man
in the afternoon I don't want to think
in terms of these small categories man
I'm so much bigger than that you know
okay so he's just talking like every
pompous college junior you've ever met
who is a liberal with Notions of
grandeur but then what do you say he
goes
but in returning to the body
my mind feels androgynous mind meaning
not a physical thing but a metaphysical
thing right the mind is not the brain
the mind is closer to the soul that's
what we would say so he says my soul
feels
male and female
but in return it's the body I see I've
been made of man and physically in life
I choose to accept that contingency
this is very based
this is downright to Mystic he's saying
my soul is not gendered Thomas Aquinas
would say the soul is not gendered but
the body
is sexed
sex derives from the body and applies to
the whole individual the whole person
because we're Body and Soul inextricably
linked on Earth and he says so I see
that I'm a man and I choose to accept
that contingency which is very base
because not only is he saying I will not
be
he's also saying I won't act on my
homosexual desires
because I am a man and being a man
implies not merely accepting the
biological facts of our body but but
also accepting the T loss of our body
the the the purpose of our body what our
body is for
this is this is far right wing social
conservative
traditional catholic uh teaching right
here coming out of Barack Obama
what does that tell you does it tell you
that Barack Obama's a secret
conservative it doesn't
what it tells you is just how radically
to the left the culture has gone in the
last 40 years this was written in 1982
and everybody even the Liberals
understood oh yeah I've got a body that
implies that I obviously can't pretend
to be the opposite sex and it also
implies that I'm supposed to do certain
things with my body that that the
highest and only moral Maxim is not
simply if it feels good do it even
Barack Obama was saying that he may have
changed his view somewhere down the line
but that is pretty pretty based
next time someone tells you that you're
you're a social conservative and and
your views are fascistic and far right
what you tell them you tell them that
you have the same views on sex and
gender that Barack Obama had in 1982
while he was writing about his fantasies
of sleeping with men boy what a great
clip that was huh that was good right
make sure you ring the bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time